You're [inaudible] to too.
You're listening to radio lab.
I just thought I'd see if I can
get the sound of babies sleeping.
Okay.
This is Radiolab. Today's
program is about sleep.
[inaudible]
I don't have to tell
you how good sleep is.
You do it yourself every night.
Will you try and how wonderful
when it actually works.
When you can close your eyes and forget
the day and just drift off into oblivion
like a little baby. But let's
suppose that you are a little baby,
this little baby and you grew
up to become a scientist,
like one of the scientists we'll hear
from in this program and you decide to ask
what should be the dumbest question ever.
Why do we sleep and not just us.
Pretty much everything. Sleep as far as
we know. All mammals do it. All birds,
bees, locusts, cockroaches,
crayfish, reptiles in sex, scorpions,
everything that's been studied has
something that looks like sleep.
[inaudible]
it's a mystery.
Most things we sort of know what
they are for and also how they work,
but sleep is really in your
face. I mean everybody does it.
You do it from the cradle, the grave.
You can't help doing it because
if you try to stay awake,
you know at some point it's a
repressible and we don't know why.
That's a shameful state of affairs.
How can you be a scientist and the 21st
century and not know the answer to that?
There you go. Okay.
That's a pretty good way to begin. No
shame. Yeah. Yeah. Today on Radiolab,
we're going to try to correct this,
a shameful state in the fingers when
it comes to the subject of sleep.
We'll talk with people who can help us
understand what it's for, why we do it,
and what happens when we don't. I'm
Robert Krulwich. I'm Jen. Boom. Ron,
stay with us.
[inaudible]
for centuries people thought that sleep
was kind of the opposite of being awake,
which reasonable thing.
Sure. Because you know,
during the day you're
doing all these things.
You're having all these
thoughts and feelings at
night. You just lie there very,
very still. Like sometimes a bomb
could go off and you wouldn't wake up.
I can hardly wake up even in a fire.
No, I'm a really highly sleeper. Amy.
Very heavy, heavy sleeper. The blended is
it?
If all you've got are your eyes to
go on sleep can seem like being well,
like being off. Yeah, like off
ness, right or worst? Well,
both Shakespeare and servant
is referred to sleep as death.
That's Dr Carlos Shank. He wrote a great
book about sleep called paradox loss.
We go to, we go to bed every night.
We die every night and then we wake
up in the morning. We're alive again,
and that was the prevailing
theory for centuries for Dr Shank,
the awakening to just
how wrong Shakespeare and
Cervantes were about sleep came
one day while he was sitting in a class
for med school my first year at medical
school,
this was back in 1972 we had an Ameritas
professor who actually was a Nobel
Prize winner of Dr Up Eccles,
Josh or John Kuru Eccles from us.
What happened is esteemed
lecturer walks into class,
pops the cassette into the tape
deck, hits play and outcomes.
This sound well, the sound was,
or wait a second, let me
get it right. Oh, here we go
and multiply this by a hundred
this is the professor announced is the
sound of a cat's brain while asleep.
My God shake almost fell out of the seat.
This is the brain during sleep
making these really rapid,
high pitch multiple sounds. That
just blew us away, wasn't it?
Clearly while that cat was curled up on
this little kitty basket, it's brain.
It was very, very alive. Much more
than anyone expected, and it's,
this is still a little weird revelation.
Like take my cat, Sammy, Amy.
All right. This is the sound
like cat Sam. He sleeping
to think that well Sam, Sammy is
sitting on my lap totally out.
No,
there's a circus happening in his
brain. What's going on in there?
You can imagine back in the
70s this was a paradigm shift.
People were suddenly like, oh my God,
we're going to figure out anything
about sleep. Right? All right,
we have to ask the brain,
and this is the room where we do
all of our surgeries and luckily
that's easily done if you're
willing to get your hands dirty.
Okay.
So the first step is you have to make
an incision on top of the animal's head.
When you've done that, we drill
holes through the animal skeleton
and uh, and then you insert
your electrode, your stands,
and that's simply it.
A little window into their brain. You can
see right there on the, on the screen,
you can see that mainly wait, are
you out of your mind? And you just,
did you just put a hole into a kittens
head? No, this wasn't my cat. Come on.
So what was it we were doing there?
Well, you just heard was a
mock surgery in Guana actually.
And you didn't make one. I mean it's,
it's not a nice look, look, look,
look the animal,
within 20 minutes of coming out of the
anesthetic, the animal is moving around.
It's eating, it's climbing
and it's, it's basking.
It might seem like a rather invasive
procedure, but in actuality it's,
it's not too bad at all. Yeah. And
that, by the way, is John [inaudible],
he's a graduate student at the a Ecology
Department at Indiana State University,
which is where we are.
John gave our reporter
Kara older testing a tour of the lab or
a big noise here and they all have nice
hats, cheered with ego on us. These
kids are a little frightening to me.
They're pretty huge. They're like
four feet long, head to tail. Oh,
I didn't know that.
I mean they looked like baby alligators
sick that went up and John measures
their brainwaves at night to see what
happens in their head as they sleep.
In a way,
it's a continuation of that cat experiment
that Dr Shank just told us about
except what they're looking for is much
more peculiar than could ever happen in
a cat or an us. [inaudible]. What does
that, let me put it to you as a puzzle.
Okay. Forget Iguanas.
Dolphins. Dolphins. Yup.
How is it that a dolphin in the ocean
or even say the dolphins that you might
find at six flags in New
Jersey? They have to.
Cody is our 10 year old
Atlantic bottlenose dolphins.
Buddy Avalon is 12 years old and that's
their trainer Megan to Tarot of year.
Mitra is holding the mic. Anyhow, here's
the puzzle. We asked Megan about this.
How is it it hurt two dolphins,
Cody and Avalon can successfully sleep.
Given the inherent challenges of
being a dolphin. I don't, I don't.
What do you mind are the
challenges of a dolphin? Well,
they have significant challenges. My
friend first, they've got to breathe.
They're not, they're conscious breathers.
They're not unconscious breathers,
so they, they have to think about
breathing. Making matters worse.
Dolphins are not fish, so
they have to breathe air,
which means they have to
constantly consciously come
up to the surface to greet
area every few minutes.
So you can imagine what would happen
if they decided to go unconscious for
awhile. Ala Drown. Right.
And yet they do manage to
sleep a lot. Oh, how long?
Eight hours a day. Like Eileen. Yeah,
eight hours. But how, that's the puzzle.
What happens is they do
what we call logging.
It's when they rest on
the surface of the water,
you know in a log floats down
a river. It just floats. Huh?
That's exactly what they look like. And
they rest half their brain. Yeah. Time.
Their brain is this, half their
brain is asleep at a time.
That is the nature of solution.
To cut the dolphin brain in half,
you mean literally, literally in a half.
So that one half can snooze while the
other half keeps the Dolphin Swimming and
surfing just enough to
breathe from the outside.
You can't really tell what's happening.
It just looks like the Dolphin is
sort of a wig but a little out of it,
but it's almost like the state
of when you're falling asleep.
But if something happened,
you'd wake right up.
So they're in that state all the time.
It sort of can be characterized
as groggy that Steve Lima,
he runs the one of the
labs back in Indiana.
There's sort of a wig and
you're sort of asleep.
It's just a way of staying awake
enough and again, it's easy to miss,
but if you look inside
that groggy dolphins brain,
what the brainwaves are doing
[inaudible] exquisitely obvious.
It's clear as that six year old can
figure it out when half of the brain has
these beautiful slow
waves, like a sign for
[inaudible]
and you other to just,
just jacking all over the place.
Oh, those are beautiful.
Wow. That is amazing. Yeah. It's
called the uni hemispheric sleep.
That's what the guys at Indiana state
are really interested in because,
and here's the next surprise. It
seems to go way beyond dolphins.
They're aquatic mammals like
whales, seals and sea lions.
John says that all the marine mammals
that have been studied seemed to do it too
recently. Walruses they're all found to
engage in uni hemispheric sleep as well.
And now the Indiana team
led by a okay. By this guy,
I'm Charles M Lanner, chair
of the Department of Ecology
and organismal biology.
They have found this weird split brain
behavior in creatures of the air. Let me,
let me just back up a little bit
and describe, uh, this experiment.
Charlie and a student had been at the
park one day and they noticed something.
We observed that ducks, ducks,
sometimes we'll get together into
groups like on a log for ducks.
We'll get together and snooze in a
neat little lie and the birds that were
sitting in the middle of that line tended
to be sleeping with both eyes closed.
The birds that were sitting on the outside
of that row tended to look a little
bit more wary. The inevitable question,
what's going on here led to
a very simple experiment.
We put four birds in a row for Mallard
ducks this time in the lab and they watch
them sleep. The two birds in the center
of this row slept with both eyes,
closed the birds on the outset,
outer edges both left and right,
slept with one eye closed and
one I opened one more time,
slept with one eye closed and one eye
opened. It's just like in that song,
do you know? You know that
Metallica Song? I missed
it. I missed a good one.
I knew they were all bought in. This
is true, you know, no one knows this,
but that song is really about
adaptive sleeping behavior in dogs.
The outer eye, the eye that
was faced away from the group,
the eye that was facing towards where
potential predators might come from that
stayed open. At this point,
Charlie had a pretty good idea of what
was going on because he knew that inside
bird brains, each eye is attached
to the opposite hemisphere.
The left eye is attached
to the right hemisphere.
The right eye is attached
to the left hemisphere,
so his team and planted some electrodes
to measure what the duck brains were
doing and like the dolphins,
the ducks two were sleeping one
half of their brain at a time.
The bird could simultaneously
sleep and be awake.
Not only that, here's the
cool part. After a few hours,
what happened was is that the birds
that were on the outer edge then would
rotate, stand up,
turn around 180 degrees and then sit
back down and the other I would then get
sleep and consequently the opposite
hemisphere would get some sleep.
When we saw that, we said, Oh
yeah, this is my back. Good, good.
Because right there in the docs was the
perfect illustration of what these guys
think. It's all about you got
asleep for whatever reason. Right?
Sleep is dangerous.
Danger, danger, danger.
That's the headline for dolphins. The
main dangerous, drown danger, danger.
You know, for ducks getting eaten,
pager ain't ducks have to sleep nature,
but how can they nature when
lurking in the darkness or foxes?
Wolves in a hundred other eaters
of ducks. Do you like snakes?
I don't know. I don't dislike snakes.
He's good man. Good man. In another nifty
experiment, John took the residents,
snake Montes,
big snake. He is.
What about a four foot long python
and at night you're so cute.
John Brought Monte the python into the
room where his iguanas sleep and he
terrifies that really well.
I mean Monte was in a cage so he
couldn't really hurt the Iguanas.
But as soon as that snake appeared,
all the lizards popped one eye over
and they train that
open eye right on Monte,
the snake snake in the
room and they'll watch it.
When I oh night that Steve Lima
again, they don't like these names.
That's for sure.
And then remove the snake from the room
the next day and they're still looking
for the next night or two. So
they keep one eye, you know,
trained on that door for a
few more days or three days.
They go back to a regular sleep.
Whoa.
[inaudible]
so what does this all mean? Well, think
about this. Okay. All the sea mammals,
they do it right. We'll list
the ones I've been studied.
All the flying creatures, they do
it. The reptiles seem to do it too.
Who does that leave? You mean? Who's left?
Not Sleeping with a half a brain on
in the other half a brain off. Yeah.
Cool.
Um, us, we may be the strange ones. Well,
it is sort of strange in that terrestrial
mammals can't do it for estriol
mammals. Just for some reason to
have lost the ability to do this.
That all mammals says, John to terrestrial
mammals, the ones that live on land.
Ah, and here's this
theory. Sometime long ago,
our scaly ancestor wanted up on the land
and thought, I think I'll dig a hole.
Yeah, I'm going take a
hole. The hole was dark.
And it was safe and for the first
time, millions of years of evolution,
that little creature closed both eyes.
Ah,
[inaudible]
and so we lost it. Totally
speculative theory of course.
But the basic idea though is if you are
protected and you can afford to close
both eyes conk out completely.
And that simple idea of safety that
explains while these guys think almost
everything where you sleep, how
you sleep, how long you sleep,
it all boils down to two words.
Predation risk per dation,
risk prediction risk,
which is really just a fancy way
of saying generally speaking,
just your risk of being killed,
the risk of being eaten. Now
what does this have to
do with us? Here we are,
top of the food chain in our warm
beds, nice warm bed lock door,
a locked door covers
maybe a nice neighborhood,
a good police force looking
after you at nighttime
and you live in a country that has
a very secure living environment.
You would think that this whole predation
risk idea has nothing to do with us.
Wow.
So there's a few studies that have looked
at a c sleep patterns where people are
sleeping in novel environments.
What's a novel environment?
Did you mean like a hotel
that first night at a hotel?
Why is it no one could sleep well that
first night at a hotel on your first
night of sleeping in a hotel room,
you generally have less rem sleep and
less and deep slow wave sleep relative to
sleeping in your house. I,
I suffered from that myself.
I don't sleep well in hotel rooms,
especially if it's just one night
per place or something I have.
My sleep is terrible.
There are some folks that actually
hypothesized they're at certain Predator
relays in the brain,
danger, danger, danger,
and that these circuits to
remain active at all times.
Now what does that, it's true that, yeah,
we all have buried deep in our reptile
brain as sort of Predator alert system
perhaps in some of us it's
a little too sensitive.
Okay. We're in the sleep lab at the
Minnesota Regional Sleep disorders center,
mission control, we call it. We're
viewing the typical sleep terror episode.
This little girl who is a five years
old would engage in these sleep terror
episodes every single night.
Now that's Dr Carlos Shank,
who we heard from before.
We're in Minnesota now at the Hennepin
county sleep center here in a sleep lab
where he works.
We're standing in front of a grainy
black and white video of a little girl in
her PJ's screaming time.
Eight in the morning after
shank discovered an odd
category of sleep disorders
called Parasomnias, which is
why we came to talk to him.
Para means around Somnio
means sleep around sleep.
This might be the human
analog to the ducks.
People whose brains never quite shut
off completely drink sleep. Well,
this guy is interesting. He has seizures.
No, no, no. He doesn't. Wait a second.
He showed us tape after
tape. We're viewing a man.
We are very affectionately call
Santa Claus. Yeah. On the screen.
Large guys thrashing back and
forth. His legs are moving.
He's going back and forth for the sides
of his back and then suddenly he starts
to
[inaudible].
Oh, oh.
Is this real? Yeah. This
guy is in and out of sleep.
He has no idea what he's doing.
One of the interesting things Dr Shuck
noticed when you first began to diagnose
parasomnias in the early eighties is
that while they were in that kind of
liminal space around sleep,
a huge percentage of the patients would
have these visceral dreams of being
attacked.
The common theme is a menace is posed
from nowhere coming out of nowhere.
It's an immediate threat that you, you
just can't ignore. Let's put it that way.
You have to either fight
it or run away from it.
Your dreams can be very
violent. This is Martin Sabelle,
h 88 he's another if Dr shanks patients,
I don't remember someone
coming up the stairway.
In Martin's case, the
attackers never had a face.
Sometimes it was a bear and I was
gonna fight with him. He'd yell at him,
get here. That's Martin's
wife Gertrude Glam.
It was always trying to protect me. Yeah,
I'd have black and blue bruises on my
arms and hands because I was hearing
English bored. Not Infrequently.
The man is dreaming in bed with his
wife that he is fighting to defend her.
If I'm an attacker. When in
fact he's beating her up.
The one night I was sleeping and all
of a sudden he's got his hands tightly
around my straw. I am
petrified. Quit mark,
you're dreaming. You're hurting me.
She should mark. You're dreaming.
Gertrude and Martin, Isabelle are
still married. Believe it or not,
after 57 years though, she did
force him to sell his guns.
He has never been happy about that.
Well, they were quite valuable.
So you're suggesting then that all these
people and the Iguanas and the ducks
and the dolphins all have a portion of
their brain which is weary in the night.
That's what I'm hinting at. I don't
want to go any stronger than hinted,
but there seems to be, uh,
something in us that's always
watching out. Always wary.
Bottom line here though is that sleep for
all creatures is a dangerous thing and
a few unfortunate people are still
awake to that fact. That's right.
Before we go to break,
I just want to thank Anne Habermann for
her excellent reporting in Minnesota and
also before her Cara older,
and to remind you to stay with us
because we're going to turn her attention
shortly from danger to deprivation.
Radiolab will continue in a moment.